porque ante esta delicada situación de
violencia que se vive en la ciudad de
cali el presidente iván duque no visita
a esta ciudad como le exigen los líderes
del paro en cali
sí gracias raúl senador de dignidad y de
la coalición por la esperanza pues la
actitud del presidente de lo que es una
actitud que los colombianos todos
estamos repudiando porque el cáliz ya ha
creado una situación tremendamente
completa tremendamente compleja hubo
grandes movilizaciones que mantienen
algunos bloqueos que han causado pues
digamos gran irritación entre los
proyectores por los prolongados en el
tiempo pero ha habido también no a pocos
casos de homicidios causados por
policías por miembros de la fuerza
pública que han disparado contra los
manifestantes inermes violando la ley y
lo último que ha pasado es que han
aparecido civiles armados también
esgrimiendo armas y disparando sea que
la situación en cali es tremendamente
complejas es una ciudad de grandes
niveles de pobreza de desempleo de
sufrimiento destruyen tu ciudadano y
mientras todos reclamamos que el
presidente de lo que vaya a cali él se
niega a ir esta es una cosa que ha
causado gran rechazo porque es obvio que
él dice necesita la voz pues del jefe
del estado coordinando los distintos
esfuerzos
de las autoridades municipales
departamentales y nacionales para
desmontar por sobre todo esa esa
violencia que este acta ha cerrado y que
no atenderse con urgencia pues va a
seguir causando las pérdidas de vidas y
las pérdidas que esta causa senador de
julio usted de antemano en la
presentación errada usted también
recientemente y con la llamada coalición
de la esperanza se reunió con el
presidente e iván duque que hablaron y
le preguntó si además hay un es una
posible una solución real esta crisis
pues nosotros entramos dije yo a esa
reunión como un sector político de
oposición a este gobierno y salimos como
un sector político de oposición al
gobierno le expresamos una serie de
digamos de reclamos ciudadanos no
necesariamente los nuestros nosotros no
estamos como como
tomándonos la dirección del movimiento
en este movimiento tiene un este paro
tiene un comando nacional de paro
respetabilísimo nos centramos mucho en
la exigencia al presidente de que se
sentará a dialogar con el comité
nacional de paros es que él se ha
inventado la falacia de unos diálogos
con raimundo y todo el mundo que tienen
como objeto principal digamos desatender
y no reconocer que aquí hay una
organización que es la que ha estado
este este barrio y que es una
organización seria responsable que nunca
ha promovido la violencia ni la
destrucción de la propiedad pública y
privada conformada por las principales
organizaciones de trabajadores de
colombia de organizaciones estudiantiles
indígenas de todo tipo entonces esa fue
nuestra nuestro reclamo principal a
presidente que se sentara con los
legítimos representantes
y que tramitará pues los reclamos y un
pliego de peticiones de especificó que
existe para explicar esta esta
movilización sin embargo el presidente
de un autismo que realmente sorprende
pareciera que él cree que colombia está
perfecto y que aquí no está pasando nada
y que entonces no hay ningún reclamo que
atender ni hay modificaciones de fondo
que que hace realmente no ir o sea muy
muy muy mal
la actitud del presidente cuando tuvo
pues la cortesía de recibirnos pero se
lo sin duda no asumió la posición de
resolver este problema con el conde
nacional de paro y es con el que tiene
que sentarse arreglarlas